please join me welcoming Gary Vaynerchuk
so first first and foremost thank you so
much for having me I am thrilled to be
here Brittany I got to give you a huge
shout out for getting me to be here so
super thrilled awfully pumped to drink
some wine today and talk about really
anything you want I tend to when I do
talks with tech company since this is a
tech company a lot of the questions and
things that people want to talk about is
social media and how I built my brand
and why why do so many people follow you
on Twitter and all that stuff so I'm
thrilled to do that I'm really
interested in doing this very Q&A with
you guys I don't really want to stand up
here and brag about how awesomely rad I
am though I'm thrilled to do it if you
let me so be careful but what I really
want to do is obviously I want to talk
about the wines we have three wines I
want to do that and I do want to talk
about you know technology and how I've
been able to do some things with a very
stagnant wine industry and create some
buzz I'm gonna play one little thing
every time I do these things everybody
plays the Conan O'Brien piece which is
awesome but he's so much taller than me
I don't like really like watching it so
I'm gonna I'm gonna play the night line
piece which ran this for anybody
probably most of you don't know who I am
will give you some sort of feel so this
was awesome except that I was to use
your web apps in one more machine and
decided to air this so I had no time to
you know that does it out so nobody saw
us Aaron's okay or the woody tones of an
oak fermented Chardonnay as more and
more people enjoy drinking wine there's
also the challenge of how to describe so
now one wine aficionado has dispensed
with the hefty vocabulary because he
believes that anyone that can evaluate a
good vintage his ABC's Ryan Owens
welcome to library TV I am your host
gary vay-ner-chuk if Wayne's World had a
wine aficionado he'd be it this 31 year
old rabid football fan noticed the New
York Jets bucket he's on a one-man
mission to
uncork the mysteries of wine we're
changing the wine world aren't we 50%
alcohol content from the office of his
wine shop in of all places
New Jersey both very records a well all
places needs a week he says each average
is close to 40,000 viewers this is a
kick in the nards
I'm gonna trick you sucka kind of wine
look at this color this is like eating
your shoe I mean this is a lot of
leather you know like the golden locks
and the entire rainbow flavor exploded
into our face the American Dream whoa
and so the rainbow even got up our nose
and that's what's going on with this
wine he sucks
rocks eats dirt anything to explain what
you should get for a dollar when I
describe wine I describe it how it truly
tastes to me cap ronk never ever failed
to deliver bell peppers and a lot of
people want to use the wine terms cuz
see center wah and all these terms and
it tastes like big league shoe to me
then that's what its gonna be
it is absolutely attacked my palate gary
style is brash but don't be fooled he
knows his stuff his parents emigrated
from Russia and opened a modest liquor
store here in 1983 gary worked in the
family business from the beginning and
got hooked he started reading Wine
Spectator magazine in junior high by
high school he was giving shoppers
advice on Cabernets and chardonnays this
is the old store before long gary turned
his parents small store into the
three-story wine library which now rings
up 60 million dollars a year Americans
bought twenty seven billion dollars
worth of wine last year that's almost
twice what they drank a decade ago and
this immigrant son has found a way to
capitalize on that half his sales are
internet-based wine boxed up and shipped
around the country the first thing when
he starts talking to me about the
internet and all this stuff I said
that's you know
today we are bringing the Thunder his
style has gotten plenty of attention
including from critics or wine snobs as
Gary calls them they point out he
reviews wines he sells which makes him a
good salesman not a true critic for you
is this really about why
or is this business this is not about
wine or business this is about life this
is about people realizing we shouldn't
be sheep Hollywood told us to drink
Pinot Noir now everybody drinks Pinot
Noir he's talking about the 2004 film
sideways which maligned Merlot and if
they want to drink Merlot
we're drinkin Merlot know if anybody
orders Merlot I'm leaving I am yeah
drinkin any fellow and send sales of
Pinot Noir through the roof Gary says
sideways is the perfect example of just
how intimidated we've become by all
those bottles of smashed grapes
Justin's bringing sexy back and I'm
bringing Merlot back Gary says when
picking a red or a white forget what
you've heard and try everything at every
price to prove the point he set up a
taste test with two bottles one retails
for $18 the other for sixty twice in
most restaurants Gary said the cheaper
was better and this untrained palate
agrees I would certainly say it tastes
better I do I do
I did like the smell about what this but
I don't always smell my want to consume
it I just think this is a great example
of where price has no impact on the
winery one more lesson Gary says when
you're at a fancy restaurant and the
server pours you a taste
quit trying so hard and so basically the
move is cool Dave move okay alright
smell it you don't even have to taste no
because I've never seen anybody
delivered the salmon and caught it and
analyze it and flip it over to there oh
it's pink tremendous what about the
fumbling around with the cork or there
are things at the table that you should
be looking for in your cork is that
worth doing you know I'm high on doing
the Chinese football I kind of like Gary
says he still has a lot to teach and
won't be satisfied until wine is
something the new beer no you know my
hopes are that the next generation of
wine drinkers are a lot more open-minded
you know I love when somebody emailed me
and said that was one of the best wines
I've ever had a never heard of Chenin
Blanc before I loved it
PS I drank it at the NASCAR event this
weekend yes
that our freaking frog now we're making
progress I'm Ryan Owens for Nightline in
Springfield New Jersey
why not the racetrack that really is
progress our thanks to Rona Haines and
if you'd like to was my favorite part so
basically I built my family business I
turned 30 and I was dry I live in
Manhattan I was driving to the store and
I freaked out and I was like I hate what
I do and screws a Frank I can do that
[ __ ] so I decided to video blog and
that's basically how it went down
especially when lazy Sunday went viral
that's when I was like ok people really
starting to watch video and that's what
I wanted to do and so I really wanted to
fix wine wine is really fundamentally
broken in this country nobody has wine
self-esteem whatsoever everybody thinks
they need to know so many things they
don't
and nobody embraces their own palates
and all I'm trying to do with this media
and using new technology is to build a
culture where people feel very
comfortable trying different things like
the first one we're having how many
people here have had Chenin Blanc before
raise your hand
solid number so it's good to be on the
west coast how many people have had
Indian Chenin Blanc before that's good
work nice solid but the fact that
matters a lot of people have it and so
that's the first one we're starting with
and so to me it's almost irrelevant
whether you like the wine or not I love
people asked me Gary you need to code
some sort of schematic and we need to do
something so that I know what to order
when I'm at a supermarket or on the wine
list and I'm always like they're like
what should I do like I answer all my
fan email which is you know five hundred
to a thousand a day on the flight here
this morning I was very thrilled because
the air lasted a lot longer this time
for some unknown reason you can't change
the battery some I might have to ditch
it for my European trips but you know I
got through seven eight hundred emails
it's what I do
I mean people email me and say which I
for dinner or for my anniversary things
of that nature I'm very in tune and want
to touch my fans and the biggest
question people ask is can you make it
easier for me when I go on a date or
when I'm going to supermarket and my
number one rule if you leave with
anything today is if you do want to
explore wine
promise me that you'll always pick
something different and that doesn't
mean you're into Pinot Noir and you're
buying a different producer that means
you're trying grapes that you've never
had before because you need to expand
your palate how do you know if your
favorite food on earth is our White
Castle sliders if you've never had them
and that's the fundamental thing that's
going on in the wine industry right now
it's really screwed up because you're
listening to Robert Parker or Wine
Spectator
and that's kind of an end or you're
buying yellowtail how many people here
drink yellowtail often raise your hand
right
nobody wants a minute's awesome I love
it but the fact that matters you're
buying supermarket brands or whatever is
at Costco what's every easy and that's
great I mean listen I'm really not here
to tell you wine so awesome or anything
about nature I think it's phenomenal
because fundamentally once you have
Johnnie Walker Blue I love scotch but
once you have Laphroaig you've had the
break every wine changes every year and
it changes how you drink it the two red
wines we have today especially the
Kathryn Kennedy lateral which we'll have
in a little bit over the next six years
if we taste it on May 17th of every year
the wine would fundamentally be
dramatically different that's pretty rad
you know and I think that's what gets
people into wine um I definitely want to
go through this first wine we're gonna
taste it together I really really want
it to be a Q&A session throughout
whether it's about you know wine or more
about you know the social media things
that we've done so but the first wine
let's uh let's all grab the first wine I
know you've probably had already but
let's let's get into it one of the
fundamental things that is being
completely missed by the entire world
not just the US market is smelling the
wine the bouquet is a humongous factor
in the overall process of how you're
gonna like a wine so you know I really
really really want you to give this a
snippy sniff all right anybody want to
be courageous and throw out some
terminology that they're picking up on
the nose smells like a Chardonnay okay
and that makes you think what oaky
buttery
has anybody ever had star fruit anybody
you smell that although it's got a
really interesting start see the coning
clip if you've ever seen
we ate things like you saw in that clip
a little bit and when I was 17 I
desperately wanted to become a master of
wine I was like I'm gonna kick
everybody's faces in I'm gonna be the
master of wine on earth I'm gonna yoda
this [ __ ] right I was like so focused
and but my parents were really good like
really like good about things they're
like you're not drinking I was like [ __ ]
like this is the family but right and so
no so I went backwards I read The
Spectator and I read Parker and every
single thing that I saw in the tasting
notes I went out and tasted I'm like
what's cassis you know and black
raspberries and all this jazz and dirt
and grass and all this wild stuff and I
felt like that would train my palate so
when I'd actually taste them and that
really helped me I really do believe
that it is a competitive advantage I had
because in the early years when I was 23
24 25 and in a very stooge II serious
douche-baggy wine industry I had to
really prove myself and the only way I
was gonna do that was to win blind
tastings and I did that and I built
bigger wine store than everybody so that
worked too but the fact of the matter is
is that that was hard to break into you
know this is why I love web 2.0 or this
whole web movement because it's nice
being 21 and looking 14 in the wine
industry in 19 you know 95 is it sucks
so so star fruit comes through quite a
bit for me it's kind of light I mean you
know it's not aromatically crazy how
about on the palate how many people like
this wine raise your hands how many
people hate this wine how many people
are mad so I think it's a pretty good
sign like I'm kind of math on it it's
okay you know it's easy quaffing pork
swine kind of fun right
simple summertime one big thing I can
tell you if you want to get into wine
you want to learn some subtleties about
wine
stop drinking white wine cold that is
something everybody does I'm gonna hop
by the way what I'm telling you right
now isn't
minority like a lot of people are very
out of all the things I'm doing the
insane things I'm doing in the wine
industry the one thing that most people
hate is that I'm telling people to drink
white wine warm because nobody agrees
with me
fundamentally for me though my whole
career was tasting wine evaluating to
buy it and when you have a white wine
that's warm you can taste it
you know I call it the high school beer
theory right the first time you had a
drink a beer you wanted that stuff cold
as you could get it because you hated
the way it tasted that's how you hide
flavor so that's a big factor um yes I
feel that the flavors are exactly the
same I just feel I can taste them when
they're warm right I mean you can
actually taste like you know this one
actually has a little does anybody get a
little hint of banana peel on this wine
like the it you know you know I'm
talking to in ER part you know like it's
kind of bitter in a way too like you
have you ever tasted that come on Joel
you've never had inside of a banana
you're scared of the inside of the
banana my biggest thing that I'm
probably proud of through the 440
episodes of Wine Library TV that I've
picked out is that people are starting
to talk about wine that's personal to
them I had a wine very recently that
smelled exactly like Brian Chen's living
room in 1984 the likelihood of you being
in Brian Chen's living room playing Sega
Master System I just have to bring that
part up in 1985 action 85 is zero but it
smelled like his house you know how like
every house has its own smell that needs
to become a much bigger part of the
culture of wine in this country it can't
be what you read it has to be what you
actually smell and taste how many people
here consider themselves wine drinkers
just curious I guess that being a good
reason how many people really
desperately want to get into wine
because they think fundamentally on
paper it's cool the way they liked it
but they just don't like the way tastes
it's hiding
how many people are drinking Pinot Noir
right now honestly it's okay it's a
great great I love it and now can you
keep can you keep your hand real high
just real quick and honestly I'm lower
your hand if you didn't really drink it
before sideways oh you guys were all
street-cred like that you were all on it
right love this love it it's a trend
market and I'm trying to break that
because there's a lot of great farmers
and you're gonna get you guys gonna get
this they're gonna really get this
there's a lot of great farmers right now
who are changing their wine formula to
get a good score from Robert Parker
they're they're not letting the terroir
speak for itself
and you know it's funny as our culture
in this country gets more green and
truthful and nice and right all this
stuff the wine industry is actually
going completely the other way it's
becoming much more commercial people are
looking to make more extracted wines
wines are being made in the chemistry
room not in the land and that's a
problem and that's something I really
want to try to reverse and get people
comfortable and liking what they like
the fact the matter is the wine
self-esteem in this country is zilcho
people are sheep they you know they
follow other people I mean I'm at I'm at
some restaurants and I can actually
physically see people sweating as
they're picking the wine on the list and
I'm like this is obnoxious I mean it's
it's gotten that bad um and you know I
really really really desperately want to
change that because wines been good for
my immigrant family and stuff I feel
like I owe it um does anybody have at
this point some wine questions yes
are you uh see ya you're trying to
change the way you know wine drinkers
view wine but I wonder now that you're
getting popular you're getting pressure
from you know wine makers as well sure
to you know promote their wines like can
you please just talk about you know my
wine and and things sure um while we're
doing this let's finish this and we'll
get to next wine ii wine I want you to
drink is the merlot it's one with the
white label we could just pass it on
down
so before I ever started Wine Library so
the big thing that people made fun of me
or called me out on early on when I
started Wine Library TV is that I was a
Salesman that I own this store and I
have this show and I'm gonna tell you
that I like the stuff I have a lot of
and you know I guess right and so I was
very concerned about church and state
early on but before I ever started Wine
Library TV I we were one of the biggest
independent wine retailers in the
country there's an enormous amount of I
don't call pressure I'm completely on
every winery spam PR list you know and I
get hundreds of samples sent to me every
day but that was happening before too
because we're one of these enormous
buyers where what's been tough is I
built my business on positivity for
example some of you might know that I
declared today good people day on
Twitter it's getting big I'm just saying
so I built my business on positivity so
I had nothing but phenomenal kick-ass
you're our son Gary relationships and
now some of those wines have been on
Wine Library TV and I've told people to
flush it down their toilet and that's
hurt our relationship as you can
probably imagine so that's been weird
that's been very tough for me I don't
have the DNA to be a critic actually I
hate being disliked like nothing makes
me more sad than making frontpage dig
because I have to read the comments and
they're all very difficult to read you
know so like it's really not in my DNA
to do what I do but for some I don't
know you know I love it because I get
hundreds to thousands of emails a day
from people that tell me things like
thank you so much for doing this show my
dad and I are now friends because we
have a you know something in common like
that's the kind that
you know that's like you know I'm like
who cares about anything that's like I
want to save that like that that's
legacy over currency which is something
I believe in very very heavily so I
definitely think I'm on to something
you know 87,000 people watched
yesterday's episode that's a lot of
people for a you guys are familiar with
the scene it's a non tech show it's 25
minutes long and so it's exciting
more wine questions or tech question or
anything anybody yes you were talking
that you don't like the
commercialization of wine I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about the processes you don't like like
the ingredients or what it is that you
don't like in commercial wine
everybody's trying to extract the grapes
there you're putting egg whites and
they're trying to make the wine as high
in alcohol and as big as possible even
the Pinot Noir that we're drinking today
in the market tastes and looks nothing
and I know you've been drinking I could
see right looks nothing like the Pinot
Noir that was out five years ago the
Pinot Noir that I grew up knowing and
loving you could see your fingers
through the glass that's pee no it's a
light grape the Pinot Noir we have now
you know looks like it wants to punch
you in your face it's like so black and
bold and it's it's it's a completely
different animal and it's really made
for you know a couple of critics that
have obnoxious not a little bit
obnoxious market power and we have
clients who spent seven figures by
themselves on 2005 Bordeaux this year
right why well cos Parker said it's one
of the best vintages in the last hundred
years that's it that's the only reason
there's no other reason why it's not
even out yet we put all that money in
CDs it's been really good you know I
mean I mean you know it's it's an
amazingly interesting market and you
know for me I feel like we're starting
to make progress with the show only now
because my own fans the vayniacs
they call me out now they're like you're
an idiot I hate that and I'm like great
thank you you know what I mean so it's
pretty interesting anybody have anything
else so oh I really kind of didn't give
you as much as I wanted to the
the fact that matters everybody's trying
to make every grape act bigger right so
it's like you know you can't make a
penguin a polar bear right but that's
what they're trying to do and they're
doing it in the chemistry labs I don't
know what they're doing they don't even
let me look at the winemaking rooms
anymore because I feel like there's
cheating going I feel like they're
pouring different grapes in there
they're doing a lot anything they need
to do to sell line it's a business and
so that's kind of where it's at
like people have just not wanted people
just want big fruit bombs and they've
gone away from anything that offers any
kind of terroir truth from the land so
it's kind of sucks I'm trying to push
that hard yes
you could take you can let's sniff the
next wine or sniffy sniffy like the same
who's who's brave enough to admit that
they started [ __ ] on Merlot after
sideways and they were drinking it
before good for you
see that's awesome both wearing green
Big Ups to the New York Jets just got to
get that in real quick yes so right I
mean that's what it is
speaking of 2005 Bordeaux um so I I
personally actually like both those a
lot
that's what I grew up drinking but
that's kind of how I got into wine my
dad was a big fan of all those so I
actually missed most of episodes on
Bordeaux so it wasn't until a few weeks
ago I've actually found out about the
fact that 2005 is supposed to be this
revolutionary or and I was fortunate
enough a couple of weeks ago to try one
of the 2005 I'd sub wine tasting and I
really liked it now my question is is it
too late to actually buy some of the
good good 2005 both those so let me tell
you real quick what's going on with 2005
Bordeaux
Bordeaux in this country sold on futures
you buy it two years before it comes out
that's just a really cool thing those
guys figured out to trick everybody on
brilliance anyway I mean it's just
brilliant
anyways this is smart anyway the prices
have exploded there's wines that we're
selling right now for $400 a bottle that
were $180 a bottle twelve thirteen
months ago so you can imagine this
brings out all the characters right the
futures market like all the Wall Street
guys I mean you could make a lot of
money is it too late yes it's too late
you lost but not really right you lost
in the fact that you're not going to be
able to really make a crazy killing on
your return can you still spend $60 $50
and get outrageous like classic like I'm
gonna put this away from my daughter's
wedding wine yeah absolutely and more
importantly for everybody in this room
when Bordeaux is awesome
and has a great vintage it kills it in
15 and under even with the crap-ass euro
there's still some really significant
goodbyes between twelve and eighteen
dollars in two thousand five board
and what's great about Bordeaux as a
whole we're generalizing is they tend to
be more balanced they tend to they blend
a lot more and they're they do tend to
be a little bit more towards the terroir
and so there's it's just not
over-the-top obnoxious like me it's a
little bit more calm
so Bordeaux is very classic and very
food friendly a lot of these wines that
we're getting out of Australia in
California right now are just so big
they overpower your entire meal I mean
have people felt that have you had wines
I mean you know that's a big head shake
move right there right but you love it
but that's awesome and you should
embrace that boat the one thing you
should not do and I don't want people to
walk away from the big fruit bombs from
Barossa or California that are massive
and tastes so good and being seduced by
the fruit I just want people to try
other things it's like you know how many
people here have had chat enough to pop
raise your hand solid you were quick you
like shut up the pop yes how about she
known from the Loire Valley and for I
mean that's wait very good how about
Borg oi from the Loire Valley for it are
you from the Loire Valley there you go
how about Bergerac a wine from Bergerac
I mean you know you're gonna start
getting less and less and there's these
amazing inexpensive interesting wines
and what's going on in Portugal right
now let me talk about that for a quick
second I'm gonna give them a huge shout
out an absolute opportunity for you guys
if you want to drink good wine right now
Portugal especially the Douro region do
uro Hills between five and ten I spill
him now I had a wine the other it was
like six bones I was like alright hold
on the euro is a dollar sixty ah glasses
- nah I mean how in the world like are
they like are the workers paying them to
like make this long I've not
mathematically been able to backtrack
into this wine and it was real good I'm
talking kicks yellowtail on its face
destroys Kendall Jackson I mean just way
way better than the stuff that you're
buying at the supermarket's every day so
a little homework a little exploring can
open up a lot of things plus it'll give
you an opportunity to really expand your
palate and you'll find what you like I
mean I'm convinced that every single
person here has not had their favorite
great brah
today still I mean I had a wine recently
from Lebanon that killed I mean just
destroy it was expensive like the guys
like here you should buy this restore
it's amazing the French winemaker great
terroir I'm like what is he's like this
Lebanese sir I'm like well how much is
it little retail for 60 bucks I'm like
you know I started laughing at him
because that is a non sellable product
but I tasted it and it dominated and I
bought it because I want to put it in
people's hands it's still non sellable
product but the fact of the matter is
it's something that I want people to
explore and I'm not sure if there's like
some residue from grenades or something
in the vineyards that makes it so good I
don't know what's going on there but the
wine is like really got a different
stylistic flavor profile and it's
amazing it tastes like $200 Bordeaux so
jumping back to under green I was good I
was good at memory hello hello
so my favorite wine right now is this is
this red that's a got a bunch of
different grapes in it yep and it's
cloudy like I don't know if that means
it's unfiltered it's physically cloudy
yeah it's a red or white to red okay and
it's got Cabernet Franc in it and
various other types do you know what
it's called
yeah it's made by Thackeray it's called
please Sean H Thackeray yeah yeah that
wine is domination totally unfiltered
yeah that guy is a killer
that guy is if I think one of the first
ten wines I ever had was a Sean H
Thackeray he makes a wine called Orion
yeah I have that too yeah that is kind
of expensive though he's over it's
overpriced but platies is great I mean
it's unfiltered it's completely on find
unfiltered real throwback process so are
there a lot of unfiltered wines and
what's your opinion on those gonna um
there are a lot of unfiltered wines I
mean he's really raw you know he wants
it to be like you know as true as
possible
have you spent a lot of time drinking
wines from the South of France you know
Russia on the language Provence you need
to go there need to go there now like
now you should leave seriously I mean
like that's where you need to roll
because you'll find wines between ten
and twenty five dollars that are going
to give you the same pleasure level as
that play DS and and the fact that you
enjoy that wine do you mainly drink new
world Cal
wines for the most part the fact that
you gravitate towards that wine really
indicates that your DNA is in the place
of really looking at some of these more
southern rhone have you had a shot off
the pop and what did you think of that
I'm again you could have a suck-ass shot
at the pop but yeah yeah understood you
need to definitely look at language och
and Provence especially for everyday
wine do you have everyday wine do you
drink and when you drink for that
usually well you know baller what was I
thinking I don't roll like that so I
think it's great what you're doing at
the intersection of the consumer and the
retailer sure and kind of bringing them
close kind of getting rid of that the
prestige the Chateau the scripty font
all that boy D toy D stuff but you're
also telling a story and you're bringing
people closer to that what do you think
wineries or wine makers could do to get
people closer to it you know you don't
have to take go behind the scenes at
French Laundry to enjoy that but you you
want to engage with people on that level
I think what would you recommend giving
a crap about their customers you know
physically caring because right now
especially on you know in this state
what they want to do is they want to
bring you on the weekend and charge you
ten bucks for a glass what they want to
do and they want to figure out how to
get into Walmart and Costco and how to
put the right what is the why do we
spend more time now spending on what's
the right animal to put on the label
that's gonna seduce you guys to buy it
then they do about the product of
putting out and more importantly cuz I
don't even mind about the product
they're putting out because they'll be
very honest with you 90% of the market
doesn't know anyway between a lot of the
variables they just don't care about
their consumer you know I mean have you
looked at a winery website lately I mean
where is the good one I mean it's it's
very very difficult but there's more and
more cool things going on and clearly
you know as technology races ahead you
know the wine industry will be five
years behind but you know five years
behind from today is actually decent
that's when some good stuff started
happening so I think people are starting
to say oh maybe you know I cannot
believe there's not a video blog right
now
about them working the harvest there's a
lot of nerds that want to see that stuff
I don't want to see people pick grapes
there's a lot of people that do right
and so they there's little things they
can do you know if they one of these
wineries gets a quick phone they might
be able to do some damage you know so I
mean it's it's there's just a caring and
an understanding of where the market
places the explosion explode I created a
very non scalable app on Facebook the
day the platform came out it was called
ask Gary my theory was brilliance asked
me one question and I'll answer it and
so but you know very scalable anyway it
dominated and but what's funny about it
is the questions blew my mind
you understand ten years ago I was 21
and I wanted everybody who's 21 to be
into wine I'm gonna you know make it
let's go come with me right and you know
I'd come to a party and I'd bring a
bottle wine and everybody'd be like dude
you're such a door put that down to do a
keg stand you know I was like there was
no interest whatsoever but now there's
far more interest even at the 22 to 28
year old I mean there was a kid from the
University of Alabama who asked me a
question about bond ole that's unheard
of that's unheard of that's unheard of
now you know but technology's changed
the game I mean when I wanted to learn
about wine when I was 17 18 I actually
got to go to the library and get like
Hugh Johnson's wine bucks god forbid I
had the internet I would have been a
wine freakin master anybody else just a
comment about the the way wineries treat
you when you walk in short um I would
make a recommendation to anybody here to
look local the Santa Cruz Mountains most
of them don't charge for their tastings
and they make their money through their
tasting rooms they don't make enough
wine to sell them through Walmart and
whatnot so they gotta treat you like a
person when you walk in the door so sure
I mean it's give and take right I mean
or hit and miss I mean you can't you
know Santa Cruz they're gonna have some
jerk offs too and have some great people
right I mean I've been too close a
chance that's hit and miss right I mean
what really bothers me about California
to be honest with you is it's very
hometown
it's very hometown and so is Washington
I'm going to Washington tomorrow to do
taste of Washington I'm like the big
favorite there because I've been
preaching that Walla Walla Washington is
better than napa valley and then on
tuesday i got to speak at napa valley
which is gonna be pretty tough that
copia the Mondavi thing they're gonna
boo me off stage but the fact that
matter is is that everybody's two
hometown in the west coast that's the
greatness that the new york consumer has
because they get the whole flavor
they really do I mean California
consumers are we we're gonna do 11
million dollars in sales in California
this year and a lot of its California
wine we ship back and I laugh at that
but what's exciting is a lot of people
are buying wines that are from Europe I
mean there's some really great stores in
California whether it's you know K & L
or you know premier cru or Woodland
Hills I'm there's a lot of good people
doing a lot of good things but the
selection and the opportunity and the
thought process of a lot of people here
generalizing of course is that there's a
lot of consumption of local wine share
which is great
I'm down for support us I'm a huge on
USA USA but the fact the matter is is
that you've got to try different things
because there's so much awesome stuff
going on South Africa who you Crickett
South African wine at all who's loving
South African wine right I mean pinot
Tosh anybody like pinot Tosh I mean if
you like bacon bananas and copper
pennies
that's yours I mean it's all you and so
that's a process that I really am trying
to get people to engage in to trying
different things because and really
trusting themselves right not being
embarrassed like if you want to rock out
white zinfandel god bless you please
yellowtail to buck chuck I did an
episode on to buck chuck everybody asked
me to do that and you know everybody
expected me to do I don't know whatever
Oh Dee Matt do something password is it
Google
that would have been awesome how about
this wine how many people let's do this
let's knit you finished it already um
that's good work
so did you ladies are doing well already
you did as well good all right
how many people liked this one raise
your hands how many people hated this
wine tell me why you hate it sir
don't forget your palate is right kind
of taste some metallic to me metallic
you ate more metal than I did no well I
get a nice as well I mean what it has
very bitter back-end tannins and your
mouth is much drier than it started so
this is a dry wine I don't get a little
little metallo gnam bat right a little a
little bit um so this is not crazy fruit
this is kind of balanced for a merlot
it's got a very heavy dark black
chocolate finish on the end are you guys
picking that up at all you get the
little cocoa chocolate kind of thing
going on the nose a little bit let me
just show you this I think you might get
a kick out of this right when I hit home
here it doesn't work
so great
how do I get this to slide over slide
table our thanks thank you
you notice I'm very big unfriend you me
up
so this episode so like to buck chuck
right how many people here have had two
buck chuck awesome how many people were
obsessed with two buck chuck for a few
minutes
nice so really really big on showing
this show because mainly cause of my
hair mainly cause of my hair but um
hello everybody welcome to Wine Library
TV I'm your host gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is Wine Library TV so huge episode
Michael Goldberg challenged me to the
true-life s your channel here you see
here oh no no don't open how are these
things I promise I'll show you mine if I
own Trader Joe's exclusive yeah
Michael a this point on the show and
many was the worst wine I think I think
it's way way well I get a blot single
day if I remember the last relate to
buck chuck behind my customer forum on
the show depending on what state you
live on specialist in the entire states
in America so he'll be I'm going to
tackle this massive wine issue and
because I get so many questions a day
that just showed you enormous effort
that Fred Franzia from the Bronco war in
fact the matters and the Jewish people
have done that are worried about what
other news Sam from crazy point when I
did this show I was already at the front
page of The Wall Street Journal New York
Times and Time magazine things were
going really well for me and a lot of
people would have been scared to come
out and say I like to buck chuck when
you've got at that point twenty five
thousand people listen to you next
Robert Parker blah blah blah blah but
for me that wraps up my message more
than anything which is that you just
have to like what you like and I
honestly think that if you make a
commitment to just go into the store and
try a varietal you've never had before
how many people here have had Greco de
to fo zero
alright let's write that down or email
yourself I know you're techy you know
grec up the to pho how many people here
have had Pinot Grigio how many people
like Pinot Grigio yeah it's good it's a
good summertime drink Pinot Grigio sucks
globally compared to Greco two to folks
globally of course I mean I look at a
product like Santa Margherita
that is the biggest waste of 20 bones on
earth better you're better off going
seen the worst movie on earth and buying
popcorn then drinking a bottle of Santa
Margherita there you go get rowdy
already um yes oh you actually sound
like Jim Cramer a little bit under video
yeah that's what that's what my agents
keep telling everybody he's right so
whenever I go to a restaurant and um
since I'm French and I go there with my
friends and they all look at me and say
like oh why don't you pick the wine like
I already know better stereotype right
yes the prejudice against you so um you
know frankly most of the time I really
have no idea of what I do well you put a
little good facade right of course yeah
of course yeah so good work so I'm I'm
screwed with everybody here but at least
could you tell me like could you give me
some tips on how to get really good the
best wine on the menu because it's not
necessarily the most expensive one yeah
it's not necessarily the cheapest one
either
sure I mean price has no impact
whatsoever I mean I went to a crew which
is a big-time restaurant in New York
City how does anybody bet ever been
there awesome right you like that I mean
crazy wine list
did you have a good time there it's nice
right how about Veritas has anybody been
to Veritas in New York you've been there
really I mean these are crazy wine
listen and I ordered a six hundred
thirty dollar bottle of red burgundy
from 1990 which is the killer vintage de
cáncer for two hours did all the right
things
the wine was so boring it was
devastating for lack of a better word
there is no perfect science right you
know like I said before really if if I
had my way when they gave you that list
and you'd look at it and you'd say Quon
drew I've never had Conger you probably
have because you're French right and
you've drank some wines from the Rhone
Valley but you know whatever it is if I
can get to a place where you look at a
wine list and say Petit Verdot 100%
Petit Verdot
I've never had a hundred percent Petit
Verdot I want to order that and you can
remember what you like then I basically
accomplished my global mission that that
to me is that's the place you need to be
because if everybody does that and cares
enough about wine that they're kind of
into it and remember what they liked and
didn't like well then in six months
to a year you're gonna have everything
you need to go everywhere and make
decisions I mean there's nothing I can
do besides this secret software I'm
working on with this kid where you take
the picture with your iPhone and it gets
emailed and based on your friends
selections and your selections it
aggregates and your favorite wine and
the ones you've liked in pass will email
you back within three minutes if I can
pull that off then I'll have something
but other than that it's really best off
that you just try a different wine every
time so let's talk about ask God you
saved me thank you
so here's here's my fundamental global
rule about a restaurant wine list you
come in you sit down whether it's a
waiter or sommelier comes over and you
say I I need some help you know K they
usually they say would you like some
help you go yes if if what do you yes
and what do you think it's very
important we we we say it that way if
the somme he or she recommends you
something you never listen to that
person for less your life because
fundamentally they have no idea what you
like and that goes true for a wine store
as well I actually fired an employee not
too long ago because he'd not listen to
the car I mean is my cardinal rule you
can't have somebody come in and say hey
you know I need some help what would you
like I'm looking for some six red water
bottles of red wine you can't go and
recommend something because you have no
feel for the palate of the person in
front of you you have to ask them what
have you liked in the past I built my
business on people coming to me and
saying I like silver oak
I like camus I like Chateau Montelena
and I would give them things similar but
different and that's what should happen
if you ask somebody and they come over
and they say you know what do you think
and they said well you should try this
it's a great Merlot we just got it in
their out order something else and
that's but if they ask you what do you
like
now you're going in the right place so
asking is great especially if they ask
you back you know what do you like I
mean how many people here like red
Zinfandel not though not the pink stuff
I mean that's a spicy racy wine do the
same people that like White Zinfandel do
you guys like Sangiovese like Super
Tuscans you know I mean there's
parallels
will fall off but it's a progression to
the next step right not the next step
better or worse just a similar flavor
profile a little different how many
people here who raised how many people
like red symbol and have had Reds and
he'll raise your hand real quick how
many of you have had pretty moti bow
from Italy good number clear somebody
did something right it's good
do you guys does anybody have a
preference how many people like the
primitivo a whole lot really well it's
the same grape varietal but it's talk
but it's not your question at all
because primitivo is terroir where it's
produced from it's so fundamentally
different than Napa or Paso Robles or
wherever the sins that we sell are it's
such a it's a totally different animal
it can be except when a lot of producers
in Italy now go into the room and try to
make it taste like the California stuff
that gets 93 points because Turley's in
is hot you know so alright one more time
how many people hate it the last one I'm
just trying to get a feel for my stuff
this is important data you hated it huh
why it is dusty that's that's so I like
the cellar dust aspect of this wine but
that's a great call I understand you can
stick your tongue out but I'm still
gonna like it um but yeah it does have a
dusty cellar that's a great call that's
what I call attic you know like kind of
like I still like to garage sale a lot
and be like can you go to your attic
that's where the good stuff was so very
you know dusty and cobble cool
all right let's try the next one third
wine is it out here yeah
lateral Catherine Kennedy anybody have
any other wine questions or any other
anybody want to talk Jets football know
we have great trafficked
so you mentioned your Yuri epiphany came
when you were driving you know on the
road one Sunday right and you said you
were just wasn't Sunday it was November
14th 2005 so why were you so miserable
before and are you still miserable or
are you much you know what's so funny I
wasn't miserable at all right I
repositioned my family on November 13th
I thought it was the happiest boy on
earth it just hit me it was just like
you know this is not what I want to do
anymore I want to do something else and
basically I walked in and told one of my
stock guys go to Circuit City buy a
camera it's like you know it's just you
know there's a lot of things I believe
in in life and one is if you do what you
love and you don't lie to yourself
you'll always win regardless of what
you're doing
I just don't lie to myself and that day
I was driving to work I'm like I'm 30
years old now do I like where I'm at am
i closer to buying the New York Jets no
all right I don't want to do this
anymore there's too much cool stuff
going on a million people just watched
Andy Samberg who came from the internet
do a skit on SNL wine has no hero or
somebody that's doing something
interesting and so I just you know I'm I
was happy then I was I was only not
happy for about 28 minutes you know what
I mean it was just that drive that I
just knew that I had to do something
different and I did yes sir
I have more of a question about the
website that you've built and you know
the social media part of your business
so are you do you have an engineering
background and you know how did how did
you I build my Empire and ctrl-c ctrl-v
this is what I always say nice so I
didn't something very smart luckily when
in 2000 when things were tough in 2001
especially in New York after 9/11 I
hired two devs
pretty cheap and one of them Eric
Kastner he wrote spell with Flickr that
was his first big internet fame behind
my back
during store hours goddammit I actually
paid him to read RSS feeds but at this
point he's very like he's can't stay
focused that's why every product we
launched is like nine months late I
hired a couple devs and and you know we
all sat in a very slimy we had a site a
small family business I mean right you
saw that
big picture that you guys just saw the
store now but before it was four
thousand square feet and our entire
office which we were doing like twenty
million dollars in internet sales was
like this big and like nine of us sat
there and he sat right next to me and on
his first day in 2002 oh this is awesome
first time there's some really good this
is gonna be good I'm happy to tell the
story the first day he started was like
January 2002 he looked over at me and
goes why are you using Yahoo go to
Google and this is true this is true it
gets better
I go to Google I go this is stupid [ __ ]
that winter blank page this is not gonna
do [ __ ] you know I mean so but he you
know he's like you need to read Jason
cocky and like what you know we read
waxey what you know here's Flickr and so
we had this great culture and I was so
sold in on selling stuff which is so
anti what this culture was but every day
I'm sitting there and I'm learning and
I'm watching and I'm learning right and
so uh you know YouTube was huge because
we caught YouTube crazy crazy early and
watching it because the day American
Idol debuted in America I registered
becoming famous calm during the show I
was like this is huge this show is gonna
be huge which I was right but I'm gonna
make a website that's gonna replicate it
but I had very evil intentions like you
were gonna sign up and I was gonna own
like 15% of your life even if you were
like a third grader who sang right but
you know this was my intention and so
when YouTube came out we caught it real
early and I was like wow this is kind of
what this hurts well I think about but
you know back then bandwidths were
insane and so anyway um I watched
YouTube really kick really carefully and
my grammar is obnoxiously horrible so I
missed the whole blogging thing right
and I watched that go and I was like
this sucks
you know just watching it and so as soon
as video felt and I wasn't big on a you
know I didn't get on the podcasting you
know audio and all that you know I kind
of let I let him have his mistake and
then you know but when video was right I
I jumped in pretty hard so the thing
that you know you understand what is
what's going on now right what's really
happening now is that people are
interacting and socializing right social
media my fundamental DNA is I love
people
like if I can hang out with people all
the time that's I just like people a lot
like bad people too right like I feel
like they're good I feel like you can
fix them so this is kind of this whole
movement is kind of built for me and I'm
also very much into Hustle 2.0 which is
I answer every email every one and
that's like you know big time and and
keeps me in tune with the fan base and
my friends and so no I have no skills
whatsoever you know I wanted to learn
how to code in Ruby on Rails I have this
like Epiphany one day morning the other
day it wasn't like a the same kind of
Epiphany by the time I got into storms
out so but I was hot on it for like 18
minutes I have a question about the
storing wine yeah most places will tell
you to store it in a cool dry place like
a cellar yeah fortunately a lot of us
don't have cigarettes
what's the next thing is if you're not
worried if you're not worried for long
term search well if you're spending
money it's like are you gonna buy an
antique car and leave it outside so if
you're gonna spend dough if you're gonna
spend some bones on a wine collection
you better make sure it doesn't go bad
the fact the matter is though if you're
gonna consume the wine with an even the
first two years I'm almost comfortable
in saying this kind of landish but you
know kitchen counter is probably gonna
be fine unless the sun's hitting it if
you're consuming it in the first year
too
you don't need that little fridge that
you made that big investment on that you
think you needed that's long term stuff
peeps that's long term that's like five
seven nine years so I have another
question you're sort of upset with the
homogeneity of the wine especially its
influenced by mark and Wine Spectator
but people when they go to the stores
they choose what to buy and as a owner
you see what people buy and I'm guessing
that a lot of people like it like the
scores well like the food bombs they
like oh yeah so but some level yes if
their palate is right god bless I have
no problem you have to understand though
in 1998 I was the kid that was standing
for fruit bombs when nobody was drinking
them so I just didn't capture it on
video
you know if Wine Library TV if this
movement started we'd watch video and I
looked really cute when in 1998
been awesome and so I was yelling at
people saying you know what Bordeaux is
not the best wines in the world
why can't Australia and Spain be good I
think Barossa Valley is gonna be huge
so you know at some level I think
there's a little bit of that in Wine
Library TV - then I like that I'm
documenting a lot of things like there's
a great video I did about 2005 Bordeaux
when 2005 Bordeaux really first hit the
scene Joel you know you're a wine guy
you know this a lot of people
contemplated the prices were too high it
was a stupid investment the wines came
out very expensive they raised the crap
out of them and everybody's like don't
buy it'll get better the euro is 125 and
the residents gonna come down right that
didn't work out and I went on Wine
Library TV multiple times in a short
period of time yelling and screaming at
everybody who watched - by 2005 Bordeaux
because I went to France I taste the
wines and I knew what they were and so
that's kind of cool to like look back
and be like say hey say you know so
that's kind of fun the documentation of
it so but in 1998 I was screaming at
people who had no interest in treating
anything but California and French wine
and telling them you have to drink these
Australian wines they're so loaded with
candy and Spri and like over-the-top
fruit people gonna love this stuff and
they did the problem is you know I'm
always trying to just get a little bit
closer to the middle that's all I have
no problem just two days ago I did a
show on how I even I'm getting back into
the fruit a little bit more and then an
Australian show and one was really good
when I was terrible
yeah yeah I mean you know yeah I mean
you know there's a lot of things when I
look back at that it was like I mean I
didn't drive the market Parker did you
know I bought all these Australian wines
my dad wanted me to like punch me in the
face really he was like what are you
doing I was buying $50 morosa Shiraz is
that nobody's ever heard of without
landish names like wild duck mock like
these crazy sick names and but I was in
a store I worked every hour so I knew I
would hand sell them and then sure
enough Parker came out and gave like
everything 98 99 97 points which was
unheard of higher than California and
that was really my first big you know
that's when all the guys on Wall Street
were like oh we're gonna listen to him
he was right he made us a lot of money
you know cuz the wines went up a lot in
what have you anybody have any other
wine questions or tech questions or and
we got I want to break down this last
wine because that's really yeah I'll do
that quickly I'll deal quickly though
this isn't good enough to be the last
question I just want anything
so both these Reds are good especially
this last one right it's got a lot of
flavor but almost no smell and maybe
that's a function of the glass being too
small but my nose impaired heard so
let's get into wine because you wanted
to something really great we could talk
about young wine I mean I get I get some
things on the bouquet I mean I
definitely get wood chips you know like
like landscape or wood chips like
big-time I get a little yeah a little
oak monster be careful the oak monster
he will get you big-time um but you're
right it's it's aromatically challenged
which is always a problem for me because
I'm big on the nose of a wine the fruit
is really pure and clean it's good
so you know I just did something while
we're here we got a couple seconds take
your next sip
really mouthwash your palate I want you
to or before you do that I know I got
you in midstream drink it the way you
drank it before or if you just drank it
try to at least capture them in your
mind
now mouthwash it I guarantee you'll be
shocked by the difference of flavor
profile you're gonna taste get real loud
don't be scared front row I like
everybody's look does anybody see a
significance and I mean it's substantial
and you've seen the charts and have
health class right there's a lot of you
you really want to get it as many parts
into your palate so to answer your
question it's based on youth do you
taste what you're tasting now which is
kind of bitter and very dry in your
mouth
that's the tannins that's what's
blocking the bouquet over time if you
age this in three or four years if we'd
open this up the secondary flavors on
the nose and the flavor profile this
wine really he'll be on Plum the
strawberry fruit will start coming
through because if you really get in
there you can kind of get that
strawberry flavor underneath of you
depending on how strong your sense of
smell is but you know yeah mine too but
you know over time three four or five
years of Aging that's when things really
open up the wine will soften and kind of
level out I am sick unto candy give you
any if you want to watch any episode of
Wine Library TV after she's like I was
kind of weird let me watch one show on
the top just put in the number sign 18
it was the 18th show I did first and so
for decanting on Google and watch that
decanting episode the canting wine too
many people think that the canting wine
is only for a hundred dollar bottle of
wine decanting wine that is like seven
to ten dollars is magical it's a huge
factor guys I'm serious you'll be so
pumped
buying a twenty dollar decanter is like
one of the best things you can do I mean
if you don't want to do that use Abi's
something just serious
it is a big-time play that will make you
enjoy your wine investments so much more
so odd decanting I'm very big on si but
I I knowed it up a little bit maybe I'm
big on an hour as a global rule right be
like I have this global rule of a net
but for me when I decant my number one
thing especially if you're really kind
of interested in wine I mean he came
here so you might be somewhat right I
mean taste it along the way pop a bottle
drink it while you're cooking or getting
ready okay got that try to go back 25
minutes later go back an hour later go
back an hour and a half later like the
development will teach you so much
especially if you do it like four or
five times you're gonna start getting
patterns the fundamental thing to really
break this down and get to a great place
though is to try different grape
varietals I'm telling you that is the
secret the biggest secret because like
record the two fo o zero in this class a
big goose egg no hitter and it's and
it's really solid stuff and dollar for
dollar and quality bass it destroys
Pinot Grigio it's like comparing Google
to dog pile see see I resonated there so
you know seriously you have to try that
I go to to foe if you like Pinot Grigio
cool what happened to the dominating the
master sommelier ambitions you know my
my my dad was very smart at
understanding that I had some skills and
the first year I ran the business we
went from three million to 10 million
and that changed the culture of our
family life and that kind of kept me
busy like so you know and at the same
token you know I was a lemonade stand
kid in a baseball card kid I mean I did
definitely want to have a great palate
and I have obnoxious respect for the
wine mate I mean the biggest problem
honestly the marketing guys and the
people that get mad at me for panning a
wine don't bother me at all I mean
really I mean it bothers me but whatever
I mean what am i what could I possibly
do without doing the right thing I do
feel bad for the farmers and the people
that read them people put their heart
and soul into this product this is a
farming product it's tough and to sit
there on a on a platform where there's
close to a hundred thousand people
watching you
and listening to you which is why if you
watch Wine Library TV you know once a
week I'm saying don't listen to a single
word I say don't please don't buy this
even though I love it you know I want
people to embrace themselves I feel bad
for the farmers but the ambitions of
being my palate is extremely strong I
hang out with Master Sommeliers not
masters of wine a couple though and I
can hang can I can I beat them on the
written test probably not but when it
comes to blind tasting that's where I
kind of you know I'm in the trenches
I made my I made my name kind of there I
feel very comfortable if somebody wants
I think that's why the wine industry has
been shockingly quiet at yelling back at
me publicly because I'll be like let's
go on Ustream right now live blind
tasting let's see who's got the chops
and I do and a lot of them don't and
they know it because they knew who I was
before Wine Library TV so I still want
to challenge somebody on Ustream anyone
who would step up I'll keep asking keep
asking so how you go to ask Gary oh yeah
how do you liable is your palate sort of
you know over time I feel I sometimes
find that I love wine and then two
months later it just is it terrible sure
I think your palate changes all the time
is there a food that used to love that
you hate now maybe that's the answer I
mean I've done a really crazy thing with
Tomatoes I went from loving to hating to
loving sea urchins real crazy was super
down on sea urchin now it's the only
thing I order so I think your palate
changes right I mean think about when
you're little you like like three things
you like eat chicken wings right or like
McDonald's and you're like I'm not you
know so your palate constantly evolves
especially in this era now or you know
you guys are lucky of sanfran so many
awesome restaurants and like even like
chill like medium tears I mean that's
cool it's awesome so you know I think
winds the same way I think you know I
mean in 1998 all I drank was Barossa
Valley Shiraz for like a year and a half
now I make fun of it every single day
but I mean it's just where I'm at so I
think people change I think your palate
changes and I think things change so yes
so we're running out of time the
cameramen have to be elsewhere but if
you guys want us to go and ask some more
questions to Gary he's gonna be right
over there by the extra wine and I am
yeah we just thanks again for coming
John thank you so much guys